it's michelle vlad muffin beauty science
chemistry phd cosmetic chemist and
sunscreen connoisseur today we're doing
an update of my sunscreen
recommendations i usually do more beauty
science videos hit the notification bell
for those when they upload but everyone
asks me about product recommendations so
here they are but first a bunch of
disclaimers because i do not have the
self-confidence to give my opinion
without them i am working on that this
list is obviously subjective everyone
has different likes and dislikes so
don't assume that you'll just like all
of these it's a good idea to check out
recommendations from people with similar
skin to you because you'll probably like
similar formulas i have oily to normal
skin it's prone to clogged pores
especially with sunscreens dehydration
and hyperpigmentation if you're not sure
about your skin type and conditions the
lab muffin guide to basic skincare ebook
can help you out it also talks about how
to choose and use products including
sunscreen white cast is a problem with a
lot of sunscreens my skin tone is nc20
if your skin is dark look at reviews
from people with a similar skin tone to
you to check that it won't show up i
like high uva protection because of my
hyperpigmentation which is genetic my
dad is basically a giant mole i have a
video on uva i prefer products with
newer filters because they usually feel
lighter i also like sunscreens that are
formulated to sit nicely and not bunch
up under makeup and make me look like i
have face dandruff also i'm australian
but the vast majority of you watching
this are not so i'll be talking about
products that are and aren't approved as
proper therapeutic sunscreens in
australia the ones that are will have a
listing number also for australian
sunscreens spf 50 plus actually means
above spf 60. things work differently
here we ride kangaroos in pairs because
public transport there was an emu war
also different sunscreens are formulated
for different purposes so for example
most popular asian sunscreens are only
meant for going to the office so they
might not hold up to dancing in the rain
or eating a really spicy laksa for moist
activities you probably want to look for
a water resistant sunscreen instead it's
also good to avoid roasting in the sun
even with sunscreen on and to layer your
protection use sun protective clothing
hats and sunglasses even if you try
really hard you're probably not getting
a perfect layer of sunscreen so if you
have a few other types of protection
you'll probably still get good
protection overall your swiss cheese
holes are unlikely to line up and for
all of these you'll want to be applying
around a quarter teaspoon for your face
half a teaspoon for face neck and ears
check out my sunscreen questions video
for more about how to use sunscreen all
of these products were given to me as pr
samples or as part of the sponsorship
but 95 of the sunscreens i've been given
haven't made it onto this list so i do
have standards all right let's pick up
some sunscreens
okay so for legal reasons i have to say
this is a joke do not drink your
sunscreens follow the instructions like
a normal human being the la roche posay
and helios invisible fluid facial
sunscreen
this is also commonly called the shark
of fluid this is my partner's favorite
sunscreen this one it meets all the
marks of my favorite sunscreen because
uh it's nice and thin nice screw top
here i'm not afraid of it exploding my
backpack this this is the goods this is
a very lightweight non-greasy sunscreen
designed for sensitive skin and it's
pretty much invisible after you apply it
it's fragrance free absorbs easily into
skin doesn't clog pores and sits nicely
under makeup it's just a comfortable
daily sunscreen it's also formulated to
not sting eyes and that seems to be true
for most people who have reviewed this
eye sting seems to vary a lot though and
so far i don't think there's any real
pattern with which ingredients sting or
not it changes a lot from person to
person the packaging is also really nice
the liquid texture in this packaging
with the small drop opening also means
there's less product wastage unless your
partner decides to apply it to us back
one day for no apparent reason because
some of us are unable to function in
polite society there's a very similar
looking product in the u.s so be careful
check the ingredients to make sure
you're buying the australian and
european version with the newer filters
bio-uv aqua rich watery essence this is
the 2019 version which as of right now
is the newest version sort of there's a
2021 light up version with a white cast
on purpose which is actually a common
thing with asian sunscreen so check
which one you're buying this one doesn't
have a white cast and it's one of the
most popular asian sunscreens the watery
essence line is famous for having this
really nice and light fresh non-sticky
feeling on your face it's designed to
work as a foundation primer as well
although it can peel a little bit with
some foundations i'm guessing it's
because it's water resistant water
resistant sunscreens tend to peel a bit
more because of the extra film forming
ingredients that help them stay in place
this says it's 80 minutes water
resistant from what i can tell there's
no official water resistance standard in
japan and there are a bunch of different
standards around the world so it's hard
to work out exactly how water resistant
it is after 80 minutes but it is one of
the lightest least pilly water-resistant
sunscreens out there alcohol is quite
high on the ingredients list which
generally isn't a problem because this
has a lot of moisturizing ingredients as
well to balance out any drying alcohol
isn't necessarily bad in skincare i have
a video that goes through all the
evidence on that
but some people can have issues with it
so if that's you this might not be the
best option but a lot of people with
sensitive skin do love this sunscreen it
also has a mild floral scent once the
alcohol smell goes away the biggest
downside to this sunscreen and a lot of
japanese sunscreens in general is that
they tend to reformulate them every
couple of years which makes it really
confusing to work out which one you're
buying and which one people are
reviewing but it's great from a
technology point of view this version
was updated with encapsulated uv filters
that they call the micro defense system
it helps the sunscreen form a more
continuous film on skin beauty of choice
on release sunrise and probiotics is a
korean sunscreen and it's currently the
sunscreen i've been recommending the
most i know some people are a bit
skeptical about korean sunscreens but
this is manufactured by colmar who are
widely recognized as the top korean
sunscreen producer the spf has been
certified by two labs in two different
countries and it's actually approved as
a sunscreen in korea which is not the
case with all korean sunscreens so this
is probably one of the most legit korean
sunscreens it's really lightweight with
a non-sticky moisturizing finish similar
to a light moisturizer even if you apply
lots of it it doesn't clump up or get
cakey under makeup there's no white cast
on light and medium skin but i have seen
it show up on darker skin
it has no fragrance and no alcohol if
those are problems for your skin the
only issue is that this is designed to
be lightweight and wash off easily so if
you're sweaty or moving around a lot
very vigorously eating a spicy laksa
this probably won't be as appropriate
but it's great as an everyday sunscreen
maybe for a mild lux a day in terms of
skincare ingredients it has rice
extracts which are meant to be great for
hydration and for sensitive skin there's
glycerin which is also great for
hydration there's niacinamide and
adenosine which are brightening and
anti-wrinkle ingredients used in a lot
of korean functional cosmetics isn't
tree hyaluronic acid airy sun stick is a
new entry to my list
this really intrigued me because this is
the sunscreen that isn't really
recommend for oily and combination skin
and to me sticks have always been on the
heavy side but i think i have to change
my opinion this is extremely light and
non-sticky it glides on super smoothly
and is designed to not clump up even
over makeup the stick has a droplet
shape that's designed to make it easier
to apply on the curves of your face so
next to your nose and around your eyes
like the beauty of chosen sunscreen it's
made by colma and is properly approved
in korea it also has niacinamide and
adenosine and is approved as a
brightening and anti-wrinkle functional
cosmetic in korea it also has eight
types of hyaluronic acid in it which
means there are lots of different
molecular sizes which can sink into skin
at different depths and give more
well-rounded hydration there's also a
bunch of antioxidants and ceramide the
biggest downside this is very small 22
grams which is less than half the size
of the watery sunja which is another
isn't tree sunscreen that's coming up in
my recommendations spoiler but it's more
expensive as well it's also a bit tricky
to be confident about how much of a
stick you need to apply the aed website
recommends four swipes but i'm not
really sure how they came up with that
number i think sticks are really useful
though they usually have waxy
ingredients that tend to stay put on
skin a bit better than a lot of lotions
so if you have a great sunscreen that
burns your eyes try using a stick around
your eyes and putting the stinging
sunscreen on the rest of your face you
can also layer a translucent powder on
top to try to keep it in place even more
the neutrogena shear zinc stick is
another great option for this
i think if you get a lot of icing a zinc
stick is probably your safest option on
top of the benefits of having a stick
you also avoid chemical sunscreens some
of those can cause a lot of sting
although i also know some people who
only get stinging with mineral
sunscreens like i said ice sting is just
all over the place ultraviolet supreme
screen is an australian sunscreen that's
their all-rounder product meant for all
skin types it's hydrating so it doubles
up as a moisturizer but has a satin
finish and works well as a primer under
makeup it has what they describe as a
clean sort of scent and it has a bunch
of antioxidants in it as well and it has
my favorite type of sunscreen packaging
a pump top they're just so handy and it
makes it easy to remember how much you
need to use i really love that
ultraviolet sunscreens were developed by
women who have a lot of experience
making products for a multi-step routine
so their sunscreens tend to work well
for morning routines where the sunscreen
might need to be layered with other
skincare and makeup products some brands
don't really seem to take that into
account and you end up looking like your
skin is kind of falling off which is not
the nicest look but the whole
ultraviolet line was purposely designed
to play well with other products so i
think that's why they've gotten so
popular as well as australia you can get
ultraviolet in a whole bunch of uk
retailers they have a few other really
popular sunscreens too like the queen
screen which is for dry skin the cancer
council of face day wear fluid is
another new entry on my list it's
another western lightweight fluid
sunscreen launched late 2021 i think
they might have been inspired by the la
roche-posay fluid it's a bit more
affordable though so it hurts less if
someone decides to empty half the bottle
on their back it comes in a handy pump
which also makes it more likely that
you'll catch them before that happens
it's recommended for combo and oily skin
absorbs quickly dries smoothly on skin
and has a few mattifying ingredients in
terms of icing people have said that it
stings less than some of the other
cancer cancer sunscreens like the face
day wear mat but it can still sting so
be warned i think my favourite thing
about it is that it funds the cancer
council who do a lot of cancer research
and provide cancer related services
mecca recently ish reformulated their to
say face sunscreen
look the last few years old just one big
blur i think it was late 2020 the old
version was super popular in australia
so this is the new version it's been
designed to copy the original all the
inactive ingredients are the same but it
does have slightly different filters
they got rid of oxybenzone which isn't
that bad an ingredient really but it's
the sunscreen active that gets all the
blame it's like the jar jar bings of
sunscreen ingredients and it's actually
quite rare to see oxybenzone in
australian sunscreens so i'm guessing
that's why they changed it so they took
oxybenzone out and added bemotrizenol
also called tenosov s which is a newer
photostable filter that's mostly used to
boost uva protection it's one of my
favorite sunscreen ingredients mecca is
a beauty store in australia a lot like
sephora so their sunscreen was purposely
designed with makeup wearers in mind
it's lightweight and non-greasy and sits
under foundation really nicely it has a
pretty matte finish and has some
moisturizing ingredients and
antioxidants like sodium pca vitamin e
and pygnogenol it has a moderately
strong floral scent and a few people on
the mecca website have said that it
stings their eyes so watch out for that
one really good thing about this is that
there's a mini 30 gram version as well
as this 75 gram one so you can test it
out thoroughly if you're in australia
you can also just go into the store and
try it on ultraceutical's mattifying
daily moisturizer is the daily sunscreen
that i've been recommending for the
longest it's a mattifying sunscreen that
absorbs quickly there are silica
microspheres in it that absorb excess
skin oil and diffuse light to give a
matte look which is why it's recommended
for oily skin but it also has a lot of
moisturizing ingredients in it like my
favorite glycerin as well as shea butter
hyaluronic acid panthenol and
niacinamide to give a boost of moisture
to your skin it doesn't clog pores it
sinks into skin quickly and there's no
whiteness it comes in a handy pump tube
over the last five-ish years i've been
recommending this sunscreen a lot of
people have asked me about the
relatively low spf 30. i think spf 30 is
fine for everyday use if you're not
getting a lot of sun especially if you
can apply a lot of it comfortably since
spf depends on the amount the biggest
sunscreen study that discovered a lot of
the anti-aging and anti-cancer benefits
of daily sunscreen was done using spf 16
in the sunniest part of australia their
kangaroo pouches actually have air con
now but it does feel a bit low since
everything else on the market is usually
at least spf 50 now so i was pretty
happy to see that there's now an spf 50
version and it looks like it has similar
ingredients the reviews i've seen are
very promising there is also a hydrating
version for drier skin ultrasuuticals
products are on the expensive end but i
don't mind as much because they're a
smaller brand and they do a lot of
clinical testing and original research
for example they published this paper
which is one of the most heavily cited
and ripped off papers about vitamin c if
you see a table about vitamin c
derivatives they probably got it off
this so the money is going to something
better than i don't know paying a
celebrity to endorse it this is a
special use sunscreen i wanted to
mention the naked sundae's hydrating
glow mist this is what i recommend for a
quick sunscreen top up over your makeup
this is a pump spray rather than an
aerosol spray i've talked before about
why i don't like aerosols and it has
pretty detailed instructions on how to
apply it which i really like i have seen
some people say that their spray
packaging started leaking after they had
it in their bag for a bit but that
hasn't happened to mine this is
non-sticky non-greasy has a bunch of
hydrating ingredients in it and says it
doesn't need to be rubbed in a spray
wouldn't be my top choice for
reapplication if you're getting a lot of
sun i'd recommend a proper reapplication
of a regular lotion product you can
check out my sunscreen questions video
for more about that
now let's have a moment of silence for
the sunscreens that have exited my
recommendations since last year anessa
perfect uv milk the 2020 version was on
my list but i haven't tried the newest
2022 version which has a blue label and
currently is even more expensive than
the 2020 version the old one was a bit
heavy in texture for an asian sunscreen
but it worked really nicely under makeup
with no pilling despite being water
resistant people said that the new
version is a bit heavier and shinier i
can also confirm that the canmake
mermaid gel was reformulated in 2020 i
think there were still some tubes of the
old version floating around when i did
my last video but the new version
apparently has more of a white cast and
it's a bit more drying as clay action
day moisturizer also got reformulated
and i haven't tried the new version yet
but i've heard it's quite different now
for some honorable mentions isn't true
watery sun gel is what i recommend if
you have drier skin and you found that
asian sunscreens aren't necessarily
moisturizing enough this has a heavier
texture and is designed for dry and
sensitive skin it's been clinically
tested to not irritate skin there's no
white cast no fragrance and no alcohol
this hits on a lot of the same points as
the airy sunstick manufactured by colmar
approved in korea brightening and
anti-wrinkle functional cosmetic with
niacinamide and adenosine multi-layered
hydration from eight types of hyaluronic
acid the spf and pa ratings have also
been independently tested isn't tree
recommends this for outdoor activities
but there's no official water resistance
rating so
i probably wouldn't recommend it for
hardcore exercise or like doing push-ups
while eating laksa but it might be a bit
more durable than other korean
sunscreens it's also recommended for
application over makeup i think a lot of
lightweight sunscreens are really good
for this i have a video on how to do
that if you want to check that out also
note that they introduced new packaging
for this which is why it looks a bit
different from the tube you saw in my
previous reviews cancer council face
daywear matte moisturizer cancer council
face day wear matte has a lightweight
easy to apply texture it's moisturizing
gives a matte finish on skin and it's
fragrance free this is the invisible
version it's really popular it won an
award from the website beauty heaven
it's quite affordable at 15 for 75 grams
here is the filter combo i'm quite
surprised that it uses avobenzone as the
only uva filter since we do have newer
ones available here but the fluid which
has bmt and mbbt was only launched last
year so maybe they're rolling them out
gradually it seems to be a similar
formula to the audi ombre daily defense
and the natio daily defense they all
have the same filters at the same
percentages as well as the same inactive
ingredients on the topic of this
sunscreen i wanted to also shout out the
face day wear bb cream matte in the
light tint which i love this is
technically a cosmetic sunscreen in
australia rather than a proper
therapeutic sunscreen so it isn't
regulated as strictly but sunscreens are
cosmetics in a lot of other countries
this seems to be a very similar formula
to the matte moisturizer based on the
ingredients list but it's tinted and
it's lightly tinted enough that you can
apply a full sunscreen sized amount but
still look normal and this actually
makes my skin look so nice and still so
natural but it stings my eyes i think
it's the sunscreen actors combo i
actually liked it so much that i kept
trying it for a full week i was in so
much denial but i've also seen lots of
reviews of this where people didn't have
this issue so i think there's some luck
involved so this is perfect for the
sunscreen stick trick just for
australians or if you're visiting
australia i'd recommend trying the
woolworth's coles and audi 2.20
sunscreens they're ridiculously cheap
and they're much more lightweight than a
lot of more expensive sunscreens i've
tried they leave a shiny sticky finish
but you can powder over that to get rid
of it and they're also four hours water
resistant and if you don't like them on
your face then you can use them on your
body they're super comfortable there too
some councils actually give out free
tubes of these in the public kangaroos i
also wanted to mention evie evie are a
swedish brand sold in the eu and they
use the technology that gets the
sunscreen to lock into the top layers of
skin so it doesn't rub off as easily
it's very cool i've talked about the
data backing up their longwear claims
before now for my us viewers you always
ask me for recommendations that you can
actually buy in your stores but
your country hasn't approved a lot of
the newer sunscreen ingredients that are
basically standard in australia and
these ingredients make it a lot easier
to formulate high protection sunscreens
that are still really lightweight and
comfortable to wear but you do have a
few that i'd recommend bondi sans
fragrance free lotion was developed and
approved in australia so it meets our
highest standard for broad spectrum
which is the same as the one in the eu
the us has a lower standard so a lot of
sunscreens that count as broad spectrum
in the us don't count as broad spectrum
here this is a fast absorbing sunscreen
and it's four hours water resistant you
can get it in the uk as well and it had
a big moment on social media where
everyone was raving about it and that
sort of highlighted to me how lucky we
are in australia to have so many good
brands working on great sunscreens from
the ingredients list the face and body
versions look like they might be the
same formula elta md uv clear is a new
entry on my list it's probably the most
popular elta md sunscreen elta md is a
brand that's sold in a lot of skin
clinics it's very lightweight and silky
it's meant to be good for sensitive skin
including skin prone to acne and rosacea
and it applies clear with no residue i'm
not entirely sure it would meet the
broad spectrum requirements for
australia or the eu with its filters but
it is broad spectrum in the us and it's
very wearable so if you're not getting a
lot of sun this is a pretty good option
mineral sunscreens that use titanium
dioxide or zinc oxide as the sunscreen
ingredients usually have white cast and
a thick paste like texture that sticks
to my fringe especially when you get to
higher spf which i really don't like
they also often clog my pores i have a
whole video where i just complain about
zinc oxide because i don't know i woke
up one day and decided to piss off half
the beauty brands that might potentially
sponsor me i'm not that smart i just
play a smart person on youtube anyway
some people prefer using mineral
sunscreens maybe they don't have access
to the newer chemical filters that are
recommended for sensitive skin some
people actually like the white cast or
the slightly drying effect so here are
my recommendations ultraviolet lean
screen and naked sunday's collagen glow
both are spf 50 plus here which means
over spf 60 and paula's choice super
light daily wrinkle defense which is spf
30. all of these are fragrance free and
have a tint to help hide that white cast
they still aren't entirely invisible on
darker skin though for very dark skin
you're going to need a chemical or combo
sunscreen if you want high protection
without the white cast i don't think
there's a high spf mineral sunscreen on
the market that's completely invisible
yet all the links are in the description
comment with other sunscreens for me to
try like and subscribe follow me more
sunscreen videos are popping up around
me if you want more